what do you remember the year that [ __ ]
started to kind of get a little hazy and
out of control like where it was like
[ __ ] man this is the this was kind of
the beginning of the end because I
originally you weren't a big club guy
right
no I wasn't I was stuck in the studio
and then like somewhere just after I
turned 30 I think I went a little cuckoo
and I started getting into you know the
nightlife the paparazzi's and this an
excessive [ __ ] and then like cocaine
came into the play and and you know Jack
Daniels and lots of [ __ ] man Park I can
you could see what everybody won Wayne
oh yeah lots of [ __ ] and that was going
crazy and I stopped working the work
just became second and then so are we
what do we what are we calling this like
Oh 607 we're calling this Oh 7 leaning
in 208 more more like oh so that was
kind of the beginning of [ __ ] yeah
that's wild man and then yo it's I mean
you brought all these and all that
throws I just know that's it sure you
have the most legendary a hit list in
hip-hop if it ever if it ever came out
oh we didn't have Instagram bro I'm
hearing the victims chow you saw my fat
Joe interview reposted it yeah Fat Joe's
like he [ __ ] all of them all of them
if whoever you're thinking of in your
head and my boy I remember my my girl
shut out my guy DJ Chris John from Tampa
Fat Joe's old DJ but Chris John was like
fam Scott Storch his house he was coming
down the stairs one dis [ __ ] on this
and this [ __ ] on the other and here
thumbs up the ass thumbs up the ass of
them and we're talking about creme de la
creme is what we'll say yeah prior to
them being that we're in a new chapter
yeah and now you by the way
congratulations having a you just had a
new
yeah so congrats um I'm like you know I
feel like I'm happy right now because I
did all that [ __ ] you got it out of my
system I'm like I'm cool I'm content I'm
not sweating no you know going into club
and trying to find [ __ ] like I just did
so much of that I got I'm in the same
I'm in the same same vibe of my life I
like waking up early and hanging out
with my 9 month old baby bro watching
movie once you get that [ __ ] out of your
system the thing is you didn't starts
you were 30 so it you've got you like
got it like you had to make up for your
20s of missing out on all know I was
always a [ __ ] monster in that
department but the women
yeah we're just like it was a different
thing it wasn't like I don't know how
many women have you had at the same time
at the most at once I can imagine some
of those parties had to end up with your
bedroom just being late as [ __ ] and you
and you be in this way for the movie the
movies are we talking like a starting 5
like are we talking like a 5 pack you
know what I can say this and I'd like to
say this do that whole era of me being
with a lot you know promiscuous or
whatever I always treated everybody with
respect and we all everybody always had
a great time there was never any funky
[ __ ] going on in my circle so you know
it was cool you know I think his dope is
your relationship with Fat Joe because
Fat Joe is one of those guys who I feel
like never wavered in his friendship
with you if that makes sense
ya know he always remained loyal to
because I feel like a lot of people
Chris Brown as well I just feel like a
lot of people like kind of wrote you off
man and like I think it's deservingly so
what I thinking out of my mind
I'd be fair enough but I think a lot of
times like in our industry like once you
can't do something for somebody like you
almost like get the ignore on you know
what I'm saying like like did you a lot
of those people who maybe a lot of the
people that really cared for me wanted
to believe time and time again you know
they wanted to believe so they would you
know tolerate it with you know we you
know we just after a while you just
figure
it out like it you know you can't nobody
can force you to to get your act
together you have to do it you just have
to get it together and then I want you
to talk about the project you have the
heavenly center which i think is a great
approach because I grew up around you
know my family being big big drug
addicts and I think the 12-step program
is a little dated hell yeah it's
prehistoric it's prehistoric and it's
kind of like faith-based you know it's
kind of like you know and I think that
you know like kind of from what I
understand the heavenly center is a
cannabis centric like a place to try to
help people get off certain drugs by by
using cannabis ground yeah not just I
mean we allow the cannabis and we'll
educate you about the cannabis and like
try and evaluate you and see what
cannabis works the best for you and how
much of it is it's really it's really
helpful to get people off opiates really
individual yeah and really helpful and
for me it worked to get off of cocaine
and like you know I'm living proof of
that [ __ ] you know people have anxiety
when they when they're recovering from
hard substances cannabis helps with that
and get you through that and people you
start enjoying the way feel and it's not
like a negative thing like whereas like
some of these drugs the the high that
comes from that destroys your life it's
not the case with cannabis so people
want to feel like they have something
that they can relax and you know just
and it's also uh it's an
anti-inflammatory so like I think a hard
like we talked about people who get
[ __ ] up on perks and shade and heroin
getting off the getting off means those
withdraws and if you could just dab
yourselves a collision yeah sure you
know it helps me so the heavenly centers
opening up win a July 1st July 1st and
it's in LA it's in studio city studio
city so it's in the valley the heavenly
I like that come on man
that's fire so is that something that um
like what like obviously we know you're
on
I come back trail and we know your
lowest of your lows was what was the
inspiration of sanli you know what I
want to try to help people
yeah that was definitely part of it and
you know conversations with obviously
with Steve LaBelle and you know he's
always helping me you know guide me not
Steve trying to you know to uh expand on
of course and of course it's not always
about like making a beat like there's so
much more we can do like you know dude
you we wouldn't have Yeezys if Kanye was
just that maybe it maybe it's all times
we wouldn't even have him rapping you
would still be just producing facts